well there was no confusion when the Joe
Broz won their VMA award but here's
something to think about
couldn't it be leaving his brothers to
start a band with Mariah Carey
Mariah posted on Instagram that there's
a new band in town Priyanka Nick and
Mariah I'm Donna Brian what start the
band I'm all for it
Priyanka went to her show in London she
had the best time and we were randomly
at the same restaurants Mariah and
unfortunately she couldn't come to the
show tonight because she had her own
show but in Vegas we're gonna go see
Mariah fun the guys played Madison
Square Garden last night where Jay
sisters Sophie and Priyanka showed off
some serious style in matching blazer
looks if Sophie shirt looks familiar
it's the same $860 dior she wore right
before her wedding we love seeing this
Sophie doing the fangirl reach for hubby
Joe during the show later we will with
the guys as they headed over to the
launch party for Nick's new tequila
breath Vila won his collab with designer
John Varvatos as Priyanka a tequila
drinker did you have a shot off with her
she's trying it on and she was there
actually the first time we went to our
tequila farm and tequila Mexico and was
a big part of the process in fact that
she's here tonight and that she was
drinking the Reposado with us it's a
special thing
but our favorite moment of the night has
to be this viral video of jay-z without
Beyonce rocking out in the VIP section
what do you think of that he wrote me
said I'm coming tonight
I can't wait and the fact that he was
there supporting during year 3000 it's
kind of a scenario I never thought would
happen
[Music]